i did a maternity shoot with my brothers
at a tattoo shop
all the comments were negative people
were saying my baby is gonna be born
with a whole bunch of tattoos i was
laughing but i said i'm gonna get back
at them
training first tattoo photo shoot at six
months my family was very upset i get a
lot of backlash people say i'm raising
him as a gangster a thug they're not
used to seeing a baby with tattoos
and for the people that judge me i don't
care because this is the lifestyle that
we enjoy
dance machine
what you want to wear
this is
traylin but most people know him as
nugget world fox is one
he's a celebrity
i think it's an instagram on the handle
nugget world 561.
you know what nugget
i would say i gotta uh i love that art
she's great auntie lord i see you hey i
love it i love that woman
because cover her expression when she
see something sick like that
mama i'm flo
nobody know me slightly when teaching
what does that mean i mean i'm not
saying no but this one's a little weird
she's amazing i love that woman she's
great but
but in this one she would be like
saki not that
that has to be that has to be florida
with the bungle dress
it's [ __ ] up my tick tock he made it
to 1.5 million followers and so we
appreciate that hey my name is shamika
and my son traelyn he loved temporary
tattoos and i enjoy putting them on them
listen you don't love temporary tattoos
you just love putting it on yes okay
parents do a lot of projection yes where
they're like oh that's what he likes
that's what he loves
he's barely like two years old
loves tattoos
maybe he loves art you putting him on
his body it's not something he loves
that's something you really wanted to do
to him
which
hey listen i know people who do hannah
is
tattoos
there's not real tattoos no it's not
real oh okay
i know people do handle tattoos so when
i saw this i'm like i don't think it's
that different is it different than
hannah tattoos no
but i do think it's funny that you like
dressing them up this way and doing all
this extra stuff and putting on these
temporary tattoos and putting all this
julian bling on him it's not something
that your kid likes that's something
that you like to do to him yeah
he's your little doll
he's your little puppet
trainer is one years old
trying to have tons of clothes
and shoes
we have over
probably like 150
sneakers okay this is a business for her
because she's like she makes money from
this instagram
so cool
buying that many kids for
clothes for a kid that's too stupid
because he's gonna grow out of them in
six months six
go ahead [ __ ] they grow inches every
two months what are you talking about
listen shoes are the worst
especially if you don't walk don't put
shoes and actually putting shoes at the
age i took too much of an early age you
need to let them walk on the ground for
them to form that yeah they feed okay
yeah putting shoes on too early it's not
good for their posture and they feed but
whatever whatever it's just stupid this
just makes money off of that because of
the dressing and stuff like that i would
just say this
every once in a while i don't raise the
child however they want i just think it
really sends the wrong message to
children and people in general when you
just buy them everything all the time
and money and this is what makes you
happy is getting these clothes and stuff
like that it's like damn 100 and you
know what i mean like what message are
people sending their kids when they do
this if you're not walking you're
walking in a sack of potatoes
huh
you i don't need to buy you jordans if
you're two months old
you you don't you don't need that and
these [ __ ] are 60 dollars
that's for this no it's like grills for
these children looking like diamond
rings honestly i could do that you know
like like versace bags and versace
clothes all the stuff like listen do
what you want but i'm just questioning
like what message you trying to send
your kid yeah okay oh you're fresh
you look good man
yes mommy gotta put it on i put on the
jury
to
accessorize the outfit
i think
that's perfect for today's outfit
i think trailing love dressing up
because
when he sees himself dressed he get in
the mirror he'd be feeling himself he
don't know
he would have put a whole sack of
potatoes he would have he would have the
same face
this reminds me of like the parents who
put their kids in like whatever sport
that they played when they was a kid
yeah and put pressure projection
treasure they living they live in david
same thing with dancing you see you seen
the dance moms you've seen you
you you
you've seen them that small yes okay and
they just be projecting and it's very
toxic it's disgusting some of the stuff
that's undespicable
when i was eight months i did a
maternity shoot with my brothers at a
tattoo shop
and i got bullied on social media all
the comments were negative people were
saying
oh my baby is gonna be born with a whole
bunch of tattoos he's gonna have skin
poison
it was crazy like i was laughing but i
said i'm getting back at them are there
risks for doing tattoos while you're
pregnant do you think it's irresponsible
somebody to do that while they have a
kid i mean it's just it depends on the
level same thing same thing as alcohol
they say don't drink alcohol you could
have you could actually drink alcohol
i'm not saying
hammer your [ __ ] self
[ __ ]
that all weekend long you're [ __ ] you
know that's not what i'm saying but you
can have within the span of your month
of your three months on your month you
could have a glass of wine that's not
going to hurt your baby same thing as
you a little tattoo whatever but you get
it like all done is there's a
possibility even with that
it's a lot of things there's a lot of
risk there's a lot of parameters with
your body a lot of
your history your medical history your
genetics there's a lot of things how
your body reacts there's a lot of
parameters so that's why they don't know
they've seen some cases where it
affected and there's a lot of cases
where it doesn't so they don't want to
take the chance there's a possibility
and we don't know all the parameters why
would it you take why would you take the
chance that's that's it yes hepatitis b
i guess is the big one yeah which is
just it's true that is really just if
you're infected but i mean they would
advise against but the the
the ink that we have now
the ink that we have now in tattoos is
not something that is
as lethal as before
before it used to be like lead and
attack like this is mercury yes
yeah they used that's what i was about
to say so there's a little that
see that's what i was about to say there
used to be a lot of [ __ ] in the tattoos
now that's why i was waiting to get
tattooed as a matter of fact i wanted a
tattoo since i was 18 years old the
first time i got a tattoo i was 32
because i waited i want to see there's a
bunch of dusty ass tattoo i've seen
people not being able to ink yourself in
ink black black skin and over
compensating scarring you and stuff like
that your your tattoo coming up like you
know and so so i wanted to wait and
that's the thing and that i was able to
research what's in the ink what am i
putting in my body
all of that stuff now it's a bit
different so there's a little bit less
risk but still why would you take the
chance but i don't really think that
it's getting a tattoo yeah getting a
tattoo while you're pregnant i think i
personally think it's the least of your
worries but whatever
trailing first tattoo was when he was
six months
and
just the detail of it it was just so
amazing hey liz hey y'all
look at it
[Music]
my celebrity enough room
and that's right i'm going to get
trained in a new tattoo
so i want to do a photo shoot after
you know the negative comments are going
to come behind this right
when i first started tattooing trailing
my family hate it
because they don't like that i have
tattoos but now that they seem it could
be something positive they love it
because when we out we get a lot of
attention and kids really love the
tattoos
when shamika came up with the idea i
wasn't down with it i was totally
against it i did not want her to do that
with him then i saw those checks and i
was like it's beautiful i mean all this
money we're making now from this one
kids instagram
it's like i want to do this tattoo and
just do this photo shoot again your
child do whatever but let's not act like
you're not treating your kid like a
[ __ ] prop
like a money-making tool and i question
we talked about this when we talk about
child actors yeah
i said at what age can a child consent
to this kind of stuff where they're
doing this child labor stuff you know i
mean when you turn your kid into a
profit for stuff like this do you know
it's a very great area that you're the
parent you choose sure
but when your kid is like the main
source you through which you make money
i do think it's something weird about
that because you start to have to ask
yourself as a viewer
you're the guardian of this person they
can't voice their own agency
you use them as a tool is there ever a
point where you start to stop caring
about what they need or what they want
to make money
i understand that there's a lot of
parents there's a lot of parents i've
had to interact with kids
that work in the acting world because i
had roles
i had to have
i had to have nephews
out here talking to kids
hey listen that's literally what you
were doing the parents are on the set
i'm talking to the parents hey i never
said they weren't there i said you was
talking to kids you're stupid what hold
on were you not talking to the kid
anyways all i'm saying yes anyways all
i'm saying is this all right so can you
take a seat right here please
dad and they see your feet right here
please please have a seat sir
please have a seat sir
law enforcement's outside whatever so
all that and i was like so how does it
work what what what's happening like how
do you so you keep all the money they
like no no we don't keep the money and
we're only doing this because he really
likes it and we've seen these like i was
talking to one this one person is like
i've been on set and the way we've seen
crazy mom in the dance world they've
seen crazy parents in the active world
that are
projecting the same way and
so the parents i was interacting with
they were telling no he's he when the
minute he tells us that
it's not working
and he's not having we're stopping and
that's why we're here we're checking
that he's being treated well and there's
a point here in quebec it's not that bad
and the state's different but here we
have a bunch of laws that they can't
work certain hours they can't do this
again there's a bunch of [ __ ] that they
can do it's very and it's very very like
it's very well done but it can still
inspire our control because of the
parents that are projecting and stuff
like that and that has nothing to do
with the production you understand what
i'm saying
so yeah
that's there's a lot of crazies out
there it makes me nervous that's all i'm
trying to say yeah i'm not here to tell
parents what to do but you cannot deny
there's a conflict of interest when it
comes to the child's well-being
absolutely when you have so much money
coming in and the kid is that young yeah
you have to ask the question should a
parent be putting themselves in the
situation where their child's well-being
does not come first
that's all i'm asking and if i'm being
unfair you let me know in the comments
i'm just asking no no it's a good
question to ask
it's a great question to ask
yeah i'll be nervous
but since i've seen where it could take
her
in
trailing
i didn't have no issue with it because
it turned out to be a positive
thing
ready to go
you're here to go
alicia help out with nugget when i'm at
work
and she can't control him
he's so smart
oh don't be giving my sugars away the
very first time shamika told me about
the tattoos my first reaction was
they're going to call dcf on you the
backlash was horrible it hurt my
feelings because i know i'm not a bad
mom
and i got
called i was typing like it was it was
crazy he'll be a gangster he's a
gangster he's gonna get um shot down in
the screen
like it was some bad comments
we're raising him up for prison
yeah
it was just bad all around
but we didn't regret it
i'm proud of shamika of the life that
she's making for trailing because she's
trying to pass on a legacy
she don't want her childhood to be his
childhood she wants better for her son
so yes i'm very proud of her
money
part of it you know
people who grow without and like really
poverty they'll come out often times and
they'll try to compensate in the
opposite direction with their kids and
give them everything because they have
nothing yeah right now recognizing the
extreme of nothing is terrible but the
extreme of everything is also terrible
it is absolutely bad to give your child
everything and much more and more and
more the extreme of nothing in the
stream of everything is still a lack
lack of balance
and that's what the problem is and
that's what we have it's not so much in
the things that you have and it's not
it's really in the balance i think the
balance is the most thing sometimes as a
parent it's hard to do it's hard to do
it's hard to do it's hard to do it but
that's what you want that's the utopia
that you want to have that's what you
want to bring the ideal
your kids need to learn
that when they ask for something you're
capable of saying yes but they also need
to understand what donates
they understand no you can't have that
no you're not going to get that we're
not going to give it to you because you
asked because when they go out to the
real world they're going to have to
learn that experience themselves and
they need to learn that at an early age
you're just giving them everything and
everything and all the time like how is
that good for them
in what way shape or form you know it's
interesting the very thing that makes a
lot of these people who struggled all
day life successful is the very thing
that these same people want to take away
from their kids meaning like adversity
the adversity is what you needed to help
you give you something to overcome so
you can get to a better place
congratulations you did that then you
have a kid you're like no he's never
going to struggle he's never going to
have a difficult day in life i'm going
to make sure i rule any and outstanding
but how do you want him to have any kind
of character
you're basically making him live for
things
i'm going to take you here you're going
to see this i'm going to buy you this
i'm going to do it's like
life isn't just about objects it's not
just about making money
you know because if it was we just hand
somebody a billion dollars but boom your
legacy it's amazing that's not legacy
you just made a lot of money just giving
a lot of money there's nothing
there's some people that like they get
that and look how they turn out
so it's just me watching this that's
just what i took away from it you know
at the end of the day you pay everybody
should parent the way that they want but
i don't know just sometimes when i see
some of this stuff it's like
people don't recognize that all their
choices are being made in
in relation to
how they were raised or their parents
relationship
right mm-hmm
i just can't see somebody and they're
like yeah you know my parents [ __ ]
doesn't affect me and this person was
super clingy within the confines of the
relationship they wouldn't go over
anything i just said like
your parents are divorced it really
affected you how they got divorced don't
you think that
in a way the way that you're going about
this is just to not end up in the same
situation as them and they pause for a
second have to really think about it
and then you have other people who see
their parents do something and they
replicate the exact same behavior
absolutely let's say um they're dead
cheated on everybody okay
then they come up as a young man and
they start cheating on everybody too
right and they never question it's like
well
people don't realize that they get their
relationship models and their life
models from their upbringing absolutely
it's why we knew had this conversation
it's like from the people that we know
the people who are most capable of
staying in relationships and being
stable are folks from what stable
relationships right your appearance was
that way yeah some of the people we know
those parents are that way and their
ability to stay in relationships and
stay stable is far higher even in the
stats it's chosen why because we model
ourselves subconsciously consciously
either to replicate or to do the
opposite
most of the time
and so i'm watching this and this is the
same thing she's not gonna give her a
kid all the struggle she's gonna give
him none of it to give the opposite of
what she experienced at least that's how
i perceive it what do you think about i
said it balance there's a lack of
balance
balance is the thing
and of course it's really hard like i'm
saying it's really hard to achieve it's
not like
i'm not standing here saying like yeah
i'm able to do whatever what not it's
it's hard to achieve it is hard as a
parent it's very hard that's what you
want to that's what you want to achieve
that's like
the goal
yeah yeah listen what do you guys think
about this whole thing do you guys agree
do you disagree
is this a big deal i want to hear from
you that's what you guys think